Strong correlations might not always be a good
thing. Let's hear from Mora about why we
look at correlation in the first place, and
what it can tell us about two variables.
>> So in addition to doing scatter plots where you can visually
see how related two variables are typically, I will actually measure their
correlation coefficient to really quantify how
correlated they are. This is really
important, because a lot of the data that I work with is correlated
with each other. So, for example, looking at Facebook
data, how many status updates someone posts in a month
is really highly correlated usually with how many days
in the last month they logged in, or how many
friends they have, or how many photos they uploaded
in the last Month. All of these variables are typically
very highly related, and it's usually because they all kind
of measure the same thing. It's how engaged someone is.
And so typically, when I'm working on a problem and I'm
going to be doing some kind of regression where I'm modeling something,
I'm going to be throwing some of these variables into the regression.
And one of the assumptions of regression is these variables are
independent of each other. And so if any two are too
highly correlated with each other, it will be really difficult to
tell which ones are actually driving the phenomenon. And so it's
important to measure the correlation between your variables first, often because
it'll help you determine which ones you don't actually want to throw in
together, and it might help you decide which ones you actually want to keep.